Heather, Tipperary,
Ireland. In the ISSU.
As someone that cannot vote in the upcoming elections,
I'm calling for the voting age to be lowered
for better student participation,
more meaningful youth engagement,
decision making and better education.
Because there's nothing about us without us.
Wicklow, Ireland.
Irish Second Level Students Union.
If I was a voter this June,
I'd be voting for Equality,
student participation and education funding.
Muhammad, am County mayor.
Irish Cyclone Students Union.
As a first time voter, I'm voting for meaningful youth participation,
education funding and school student rights.
Leo. Uh, Dublin,
Ireland. Um,
with the Irish Second Level Students Union,
the ISSU. Um,
I'm a first time voter. I'll be voting in June this year on June 7th.
And what I really wanna vote for and what I will be voting for
is for school student rights
to lowering the voting age of 16
and increasing and securing funding for Erasmus,
ensuring its longevity
and also funding of youth participation projects.
2 3 students, 4